DINNER, 1874.
I AM DAVID SPUNT.
HAVE A GOOD NIGHT.
>> Sean: ALL STARTED AS AN
INTERNET JOKE THAT ENDED UP
GETTING GLOBAL ATTENTION.
HUNDREDS OF 8 MILLION HUNTERS
HAVE GATHERED IN NEVADA.
YOU'RE THE GOVERNMENT FACILITY
KNOWN AS AREA 51.
YOU MIGHT REMEMBER BUILDING A
CAREER ON TALKING ABOUT THIS ON
AN EFFORT TO QUOTE STORM THE
MILITARY BASE."
THESE PEOPLE WERE REPORTEDLY
DETAINED.
TODAY WE SENT LAWRENCE JONES TO
FIND OUT WHAT THE EXTRA
CONGRESSIONAL               -- E
CONGRESSIONAL               -- T
CONGRESSIONAL               -- A
TERRESTRIAL BELIEVERS WERE DOING
OUT IN THE DESERT.
WE HOPE HE'S NOT BEEN ABDUCTED.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> WHY ARE YOU HERE?
SCIENTIFIC REASONS?
>> HERE FOR SCIENTIFIC REASONS.
WE ARE HERE FOR THE ALIENS.
>> I WANT TO HEAR ABOUT THE
ALIENS LIBERAL AGENDA.
THEY PUT OUT SOME GOOD TALKING
POINTS.
WE DON'T KNOW.
>> WANTED YOU FIRST DISCOVER YOU
ARE AN ALIEN?
>> 1984.
>> EHH.
>> THIS IS TO PROTECT MY MIND
FROM INTERFERENCE OF ANY KIND.
>> ANY ACTUAL ALIENS?
STICKER NOT YET, BUT WE ARE
HOPING.
>> ARE YOU GOING TO STORM AREA
51?
>> HOPEFULLY.
I WANT TO.
>> HAVE YOU HAD ANY INTERACTIONS
WITH THE OUTSIDE WORLD?
>> TODAY, NO.
YESTERDAY, ALSO NO.
KIND OF.
WE HAD WEIRD DREAMS THE NIGHT
BEFORE.
>> Sean: JOINING US NOW FROM
NEVADA.
HE IS OUR OFFICIAL 2020 ON THE
GROUND REPORTER AND
INVESTIGATIVE REPORTER AS WELL.
LAWRENCE JONES.
GLAD TO SEE YOU HAVE NOT BEEN
ABDUCTED.
I'M LOOKING AT THIS, THESE ARE
REAL BELIEVERS.
I DON'T HAVE A PROBLEM WITH IT.
I DON'T KNOW THE MAJESTY OF
GOD'S CREATION.
WE KNOW THIS UNIVERSE WITH
UNIVERSES.
I DON'T KNOW.
>> HEY, SEAN, I AM IN HAIKOU
NEVADA.
THE ALIEN RESEARCH CENTER.
EARLIER TODAY, WE HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO TALKS TO SOME
PEOPLE.
SOME PEOPLE BELIEVE IT AND SOME
PEOPLE WANTED TO JUST HAVE A
GOOD TIME.
AREA 51 IS ACTUALLY >> Sean:
THE SPACESHIP I THINK --
LAWRENCE, WHAT IS THAT BEHIND
YOU?
LOOKED LIKE A SPACESHIP FOR A
MINUTE BUT I GUESS IT'S A CAR.
>> YOU'VE GOT ALL TYPE OF STUFF
BEHIND US.
EVERYBODY'S TRYING TO GO IN AND
SEE ALIENS.
AGAIN, A LOT OF THESE PEOPLE
BELIEVE IT.
A LOT OF THESE PEOPLE ARE LIKE
THE COMIC-CON CREW WHO JUST WANT
TO HAVE A GOOD TIME.
OVER 2,000 PEOPLE AT THE FIRST
EVENT WE WERE OUT TODAY SO THEY
ARE KEEPING COMING ON IN, SEAN.
>> Sean: I MEAN, THEM THINK
THEY BELIEVE, AND I WATCHED
ENOUGH OF THE HISTORY CHANNEL
ET CETERA.
NAT GEO HAS A WHOLE SPECIAL
EYEWASH ON AREA 51 WANTS, I LOVE
DOCUMENTARIES.
I WANT TO KNOW WHAT OTHER PEOPLE
THINK.
BUT THEY REALLY BELIEVE A LOT OF
PEOPLE, THERE ARE UFOs,
UNIDENTIFIED FLYING OBJECTS, AND
PEOPLE HAVE LANDED FROM OTHER
PLANETS IN THE CLAIM TO HAVE
BEEN ABDUCTED.
DID YOU MEET ANY OF THOSE PEOPL
PEOPLE?
>> I MET SOME OF THOSE PEOPLE.
I MET SOME PEOPLE WHO TODAY SAID
THAT EVER SINCE THEY'VE BEEN
HERE, THEY FELT THE GROUND
SHAKING AND THEY FEEL LIKE IT'S
BECAUSE THEY ARE SO CLOSE TO THE
FACILITY THAT THEY ARE GETTING
ALL THIS INTERFERENCE.
ONE LADY BELIEVES THAT HER
PARENTS IS ACTUALLY ALIENS.
YOU HAVE ONE LADY THAT SAID THAT
SHE ALLEGEDLY WORKED AT AREA 51
AND SHE KNOWS THIS STUFF TO BE
TRUE.